hey guys good news i have a fitness app
you get to work out live with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on download feel on the app store or
go to fieldlife.com and start your
journey to become
hi i'm joanna so welcome back to another
workout session together with me today
we're working on advanced strength
endurance training so this workout will
focus on your lower body for the first
circuit your upper body for the second
circuit and your core for the finest
circuit each circuit will consist of two
strength training followed by a cardio
blaster so each workout will be for 40
seconds long by a 20 seconds rest in
between okay you will need a pair of
dumbbells choose your option i would say
either three or four or even five kilos
each so grab your dumbbell and let's
start with our warm up
alright so for your warm-up you don't
need to use your dumbbell just yet i
just want you to start by squatting down
and reaching up okay so squat low squat
deep and reach up to stretch out on your
back good keep going squat down and up
down and reach good
and i want you to remember this movement
because we will be using this movement
in the first workout good keep squatting
keep pushing back
and stretch up keep your chest up
and look straight good now just place
your fingers underneath your toes and
same thing what i'm going to do is squat
down reach up and straighten your legs
so what you're doing is to stretch out
on your hamstrings good squat low down
chest up straighten legs and back down
nice keep going let's do three more down
and up
down
and up one last one down and up
and good okay so now step
at the edge of your mat forward what i'm
going to do is take a lunge back
and stretch up step forward and lunge
back again again remember this movement
because we will be incorporating this
move in your workout step forward
step back reach up
look up
and remember to keep both legs 90
degrees and you're pushing up through
your heels
one last one on each side
and now just shake it out okay for the
first workout it's going to be
burpee squat thrust so grab both
dumbbells okay we want to start on the
floor
let me just show you the movement what i
need to do is start low in a squat
position hop out
hop in
lift the dumbbells up and push up all
right let's go
start down in a squat position and now
let's go hop out hop in
bring your butt down and push the
dumbbells up
good
so use the momentum for my legs the
energy from your legs to drive
both dumbbells up
hop in
and drive up good
keep going out
in but down
drive the dumbbells up nice
so you're working on your lower body
as well as your shoulders
remember as you come up use the strength
from your core
to
bring both dumbbells up up
one last one down
back
in and up
very good
second workout you will only need one
dumbbell okay so it's going to be a
reverse lunge with a press up so
start in front of your mat what i want
to do is bring one leg back so left leg
back as you lunge down push the dumbbell
up okay so we're working only on one
side left leg back
drive the dumbbell straight up good
so always keeping the dumbbell close to
your shoulder step back push up
and just tap gently up
always keeping the right knee slightly
bent
good
[Music]
working on your right side
your right leg
and your right shoulders step back
push up
and again
drive up good
keep going
drive up
step back
one more
and rest it out now
drop both dumbbells for the final
workout the third workout for this
circuit it's going to be a cardio
blaster so it's going to be ice skater
okay so stand
shoulder width apart toes pointer
forward all i want you to do is hop to
your left and to your right okay
that's it let's go as wide as you can
and
find your balance good
all right keep going find your balance
tighten your core hop left to right left
to right bringing the opposite arm up
keep going left to right
if you need to look straight ahead
find one focal point to find your
balance again remember to keep your
knees soft
land on your heels
bounce off
lift from your heels okay keep going
few more five more seconds
left and right find your rhythm that's
one more
and rest it out
right let's go to upper body grab both
dumbbells
lie down onto the mat
it's going to be a bridge chest fly okay
so first thing
keep your heels close to your butt lift
both butt off
bring the dumbbells in front of your
chest
open up to a fly
and i'm going to just close it and
squeeze it together that's it so open up
bring the dumbbells close to you if you
want to challenge yourself even more
what you can do is twist
your arms
with your palms facing up so twist you
should feel more contraction on your
chest keeping your butt lifted at all
times
squeeze and twist
but up so you're also engaging your
glutes while working on your upper body
twist
up and twist
good keep going lift your butt up do not
drop and now let's come up okay
this next workout is my favorite workout
it's going to be
plank row with a push up okay so it's a
push-up plank roll what i want you to do
is again
hold grab hold of both dumbbells firmly
you need a lot of wrist strength for
this so get into a plank position give
me one push-up
and roll on your left
and on your right again back to push-up
row on your left and your right if
you're struggling with this what you can
do is place one palm down grab the
dumbbell pull it pull it and when you do
your push-up you can replace both palms
down
and with a roll one
and one okay if you feel confident
both
arms on the dumbbells and roll good so
push up
row
left and right
this is a really good core strengthening
exercise and also back one more and just
drop the dumbbells okay
[Music]
this circuit the cardio blaster it's
going to be mountain climber okay so we
all know mountain climber get into a
high plank position
drive your knees to your chest okay
ready and now let's go drop your knee in
close to your chest keep your back flat
core tight
and keep running
imagine you're climbing up the hill the
steep hill keep running find your pace
find the rhythm
and just breathe
keep breathing
come on guys do not stop right now okay
you have 10 seconds left
drive your knees in close to your chest
tuck your tummy in feel your core
engaged
last three
two and one
very very good okay
let's move on and work on your shoulders
up right row two run race okay so grab
both dumbbells okay the movement is
going to be an upright row just bring
the dumbbells close to your chest just
under your chest bring it down and bring
it to the front all right this is going
to be a little more a little bit more
challenging because your shoulder
muscles are small muscles upright row
under your chest
lift it up to the front good
up
and front very good
up again
and front tighten your core suck your
belly in do not swing your body
as you lift the dumbbells to the front
up
and lift it to the front good
up and front very nice
strong shoulders okay this will work on
the front part of your shoulders last
one up
and down very good
next workout is going to be a reverse
fly okay
so again
stand shoulder width apart toes pointer
forward what i want to do is keep both
dumbbells close to your thighs
bend forward away slightly keeping your
chest up i want you to do a reverse fly
by spreading it out
squeezing the meat
the mid part of your back as well as
your upper back okay so you should be
squeezing this part
open and squeeze good control it down
open and squeeze
nice so spread it squeeze control
up and spread if you want to challenge
yourself even more
up
twist it and bring it back down okay
choose your option up hold it
and bring it back down
squeeze
the top part of your back as well as
your shoulders
control
squeeze
control it back down
squeeze
and down all right find a cardio blaster
and you will get a short break okay so
it's going to be a cross jack
typical jumping jack is this with a
cross jack what i want to do is to cross
your left feet over your right and vice
versa okay so let's go
ready now let's go cross
cross and cross so alternating between
legs okay left leg in front right leg
left and right good
if you want to you can even spread your
legs wider and go
lower
halfway there
breathe pace your breathing
your heart rate should be high
breathe in and breathe out
you're almost there guys
you will get a one minute break
after this
hang in there stay with me stay strong
let's work on your cardio right now
last one
and
rest it out okay
so that was round one we have one more
round to go
keep yourself hydrated drink some water
wipe your sweat and take a shot break
ah you've done so well
always remember
when you're working out especially when
you're doing high intensity workouts
you have to constantly keep yourself
hydrated
don't drink too much water at once take
small sips throughout the whole workout
okay
so that you will not feel bloated
immediately
and at this point
for the second round if you feel that
you know what the weights are too light
then by all means go and grab a heavy
pair of dumbbells if you feel that oh my
gosh i'm struggling i can't even finish
the workout then by all means grab a
lighter pair of dumbbell this is when
you know what is your intensity and
strength level okay let's go first
workout
burpee
to a squat
and thrust
good kick it back
bring your butt down drive both
dumbbells up
down
and push up we are engaging
the entire
body drive it up
bring it back down hop back
and up always keeping your chest forward
and open drive it up
good hop back
drive it up
let's keep going
five more seconds left
give me one more strong burpee to a
squat thrust good
drop one dumbbell okay we worked on one
side just now switch over
grab the dumbbell on your left hand and
now we want to bring the right leg back
okay it's going to be a reverse lunge
with a press up so
left dumbbell
on your shoulder ready step back drive
it up find your balance
and up good tap gently
and back up
nice
stay strong
keeping both
knees bent
at all times
drive up
back
push it up as you step back
push it back up
and look straight ahead
good
keep going
few more
give me two more drive it up that's one
more
drop it up
and
down bounce down okay
your cardio blaster okay ice skater
again
left and right left and right go as wide
as you can okay
this is your cardio blaster
push it
all the way through
right breathe in breathe out stay
shoulder width apart let's go
hop hop
fast
and quick
keep going
kick it back
land on your heels
push using your heels suck your belly in
tighten your core engage your core
and breathe
and you should
see your sweat
dripping
keep going
let's go 10 more seconds let's speed it
up
come on speed it up
kick
opposite arm up
last three more last two more
and rest it off okay let's
get back down onto the mat and work god
and work on bridge chest fly okay lie
down bring your heels close to your butt
lift it off the floor squeeze your
glutes
both dumbbells directly above your chest
level so not too high up not on your
face or not too low directly above your
chest spread it open
and let's add a twist
and squeeze your chest okay spread it to
the side
and squeeze again remaining at your
chest level
all the way through
squeeze
lift your butt up
don't just lift it up squeeze your
glutes as well okay as you squeeze the
chest
squeeze and engage your glutes very good
squeeze it
spread it bend your elbows slightly
gently tap onto the floor
and drive it back up so do not rest your
elbows on the floor
and
come back up
my favorite workout what is it
it is a push-up to plank row okay so
choose your option either both hands
firmly on the dumbbells or choose to put
your hands on the mat all right let's go
up
from a push-up spread your legs wider to
find your balance roll left and right
push up
and roll okay
good so the push-up will work on the
chest
your shoulders the row will work on your
back
and your shoulders and for you to find
your balance you are engaging your core
throughout
left and right row
push up
left and right
i can see my sweat
dripping
and
this is your effort
last one more give me a left
and right
row
all right drop it down
your cardio blaster look at me
mountain climbers okay
oh sweat dripping that's okay
we're all good we're strong
start in a high plank position
drive your knees in to your chest okay
let's go in
and
keep looking straight down
keeping your back flat
and your core engaged suck your belly in
okay stack your shoulders and your palms
and your wrists
should be in one straight line
drive it in
and breathe
keep going
okay
you're almost there do not stop right
now i can feel your burn
less than 10 seconds
keep going
last three
two
one
oh
okay
all right
you know in the next round
show this okay
come on let's work on your arms right
now up
let's go
breathe
roll your shoulders a little bit
keep breathing
and now let's go up right row to a front
raise up right row
front raise
row up
it's like i just came up from the shower
up
and go front nice
keep it just under your chest
close to your chest okay and as you
bring both dumbbells up
do not swing your body up
good
and remember
here's your breathing
and smile
if your hair is not messy at the end of
this workout if your face is not messy
trust me you have not worked hard enough
let's go
and rest it out okay
all right reverse fly okay so we want to
work on the upper part of your back as
well your shoulders
right i'm gonna stand facing the
opposite direction and i want you to see
exactly where you should be squeezing
and engaging your muscles bend keep your
chest up open squeeze hold for one count
and back down
squeeze and back down okay so you're not
just lifting to the side you're
bringing your shoulder blades together
squeeze
back down
up shoulder blades together back down
keeping the dumbbells
close to your thighs
up and down so it's not forward it's
close to your thighs
spread it up and down again avoid
jerking too much okay
this is not an easy workout so you might
need to lift lighter
down
up
and down good all right final cardio
blaster cross jack
and
good news you are done after this okay
right guys cross jack left and right
breathe in
breathe out roll your arms if you want
to
take this five seconds roll forward and
now let's go cross jack left and right
left and right
good
go wide go fast
and breathe
keep breathing keep crossing feel your
hips working
20 seconds left
bring your heart rate up before we cool
down
last few more
last one more on each side
and you are done
you are done very very well done now
i just want you to take this moment to
breathe
and let's just do some simple stretches
okay
so
start right at the edge of your mat
start on your knees take your left leg
forward
right knee down and just press forward
okay
you should feel the stretch on your
right hip flexor
press forward
and if you want to lean back slightly
good
and now slowly just raise your right
hand
and just twist
to the left
very good
and now just
keep your left leg straight and just
lower your body okay lower your body
slightly
to stretch out on your hamstrings
keep your butt down
stretch it out do not force the stretch
it should be a mild discomfort so keep
stretching
and keep breathing
feel the stretch very good
and now what i want to do is bend your
left leg
in a 90 degree position
and just
lower your body down
to stretch on your left glutes
if you want to you can even lower
yourself even more
again if this is too much start
either on your elbows
or
on your palms okay so choose your option
elbows palms or
all the way
and breathe
good now push yourself back up
bring your leg back and now let's let's
switch the other side right leg forward
and just push
and feel the stretch on your left hip
flexor
here right here
and if you want to
left hand up
bend to your right to stretch out
on your obliques
and hold it
and now bend your right
up keep your right leg straight and
slowly lower your body down
to stretch on your hamstrings
okay
keep breathing
and now bend your right
leg into a 90 degree position choose
your option
palms
deeper stretch
elbows
even a deeper stretch reach forward
and bring your chest close to your leg
and now just bring your right leg back
and i want you to just get into a cobra
stretch it up
row your shoulders and look up
very good
and now slowly get into a standing
position
and just
raining
swing your body
left and right side to side
and you are
at the end of your workout
very
very well done
give yourself
a big hands
well done you have completed an advanced
strength endurance training okay so this
workout focuses on your strength
power as well as your cardio endurance
how far can you go how far can you push
yourself with short rest in between if
you look like this at the end of your
workout hair messy absolutely sweaty be
sure to give this video a thumbs up okay
share this video with your friends get
them to join you challenge each other by
lifting heavier resting shorter and do
more circuits don't forget to check out
my fitness app called feel on the app
store and it will be available on the
google play soon as well
you will be able to join us in more
daily workouts and be sure to subscribe
to my youtube channel check out other
workout videos and other workout
challenges as well
i'll see you next monday all the best